this is one of the craziest wildest
elections you've ever seen in your
lifetime
it's both remarkably different and
extraordinarily important at the same
time
how much has the game change for
somebody that wants to win a campaign
and who's done the best adjusting to
today's game being played
trump had a couple of unique advantages
biden is in a totally different position
if your opponent has 92 negative press
coverage you don't have to do a whole
lot to communicate what's wrong
because the new york times the
washington post nbc and the rest of them
they'll all go do your job for you
he chose the perfect candidate where
they had nothing to come after her i
mean you couldn't say anything to her
because of who she was
do you think they're going to pack the
court if they win and if yes what does
that really mean to america they're
absolutely going to pack the court and
the reason is simple kamala harris is a
san francisco radical
i think nancy pelosi is a radical uh and
i think biden is so weak
so lacking in energy what are your
thoughts if jeff bezos now owns
washington post and ends up buying and
owning cnn what happens to media if
you're on the left you can do anything
you want to and they'll protect you if
you're on the right they can smear you
and claim that it's good journalism do
you think we're gonna find that next
week or do you think it's gonna be
delayed oh no i think the marginally big
enough will now
[Music]
my guest today is newt gingrich the 50th
speaker of the house and a former 1995
time magazine man of the year new thank
you so much
for being a guest on valuetainment today
well i'm delighted to be with you
it should be very interesting yes i've
been looking forward to this
would you agree this is one of the
craziest wildest elections you've ever
seen in your lifetime
oh i think it's certainly the most
unusual in my lifetime
and probably the most consequential
since abraham lincoln's re-election in
1864.
so it's it's a it's both remarkably
different
and extraordinarily important at the
same time now you know for me
just before somebody that's been
following politics for now i don't know
less than two decades
is it seems like every time you hear
that word it's the most consequential
it's the most consequential
and it's a form of creating urgency for
a lot of the voters to get out and want
to vote
but there seems to be a real feeling
or energy of this being the most
consequential why would you say that
is well you have a genuine
populist outsider who has shaken the
whole system up for four solid years
and you have a national establishment uh
which is going all out at every level
from
twitter and facebook to corporate
leadership uh to the news media which
a report came out yesterday that 92
percent of the trump coverage of the
campaign is negative
uh all that's going on simultaneously
and the difference in the
direction of america from a biden
harris uh schumer pelosi left-wing
radicalism
to where trump and pence and mcconnell
and mccarthy would go is really
unbelievably different it's an amazing
choice
that the american people will make next
tuesday
you you've seen elections for a long
time and they've they've gone through
different uh
you know uh uh conditions so whether it
was
you know nixon first going to uh being
on tv to debate with kennedy i'm like oh
my gosh you got to make sure you look
good on tv when you're being you know
when you're debating was radio prior to
that
and now you got social media how much
has the game change for somebody that
wants to win a campaign
and and who's who's done the best
adjusting to today's game being played
versus what it was maybe 20 30 40 even
50 years ago
well i think trump had a couple of
unique advantages
uh he had done a popular commercial
television series
called the apprentice i think it was on
for 13 years
he had he owned a one point
the miss universe contest until he was
very used to reaching a mass market
he uh really understood very quickly the
power of facebook and twitter
and so developed the largest following
uh in both
of anybody and as a result he's been
able to take on the entire national news
media
and basically fight him to to a
standstill because
his his reach has been as great as
the collective reach of every single
major uh elite news media it's a
remarkable achievement so i would say he
really understands it
you know biden is in a totally different
position biden basically is hoping
that kovid will win the election horn uh
i noticed that
you and i are talking on a day when
biden once again has no schedule
zero hiding in the basement uh in
wilmington
and you know but but it's not irrational
i mean his strategy
is that if he stays out of the way and
allows the country to be mad at trump
that he'll get elected because they'll
be trump so it's not a pro-biden
strategy
it's a hide-and-hope strategy it could
work i mean it's possible
partly because uh you know if your
opponent has
92 percent negative press coverage you
don't have to do a whole lot
to communicate what's wrong because the
new york times the washington post
nbc and the rest of them they'll all go
do your job for you and that's what's
been going on
that is so true watching that be taking
place it's it's actually very
interesting you got the whole team on
your side when you're running and he
does not but
do you think president trump i don't
know if you've seen the documentary
trumpster the story of his father and
his grandfather if you know it's a
pretty interesting documentary
and do you think trump was somebody that
behind closed doors he himself had plans
of saying i'm going to one day be a
president i mean i'm sure you've seen
that one interview he did with oprah
winfrey
do you think so or no and look in the
80s you know oprah asked him
in the 80s and he said i might have to
someday yeah
i think trump saw himself as a potential
president
probably by 1987 or 1988 i
looked at it very carefully uh there's a
great interview that he did
um uh with larry king that you can find
on youtube
and it sounds exactly like trump today
it's a 30 year old youtube
copy of trump talking to larry king
about
you know we have bad trade deals we're
getting involved overseas we don't need
to
the bureaucracy doesn't work very well
just goes right down the list
and he sounds he's a much younger
thinner version but he sure sounds
like he hasn't changed much in 30 or 40
years
yeah so your answer is yes he has been
planning that one day he would be
running
well planting's too strong a word i
think he has been
looking at it thinking about it callista
and i had breakfast with him in
january of 2015 in iowa and it was clear
that he was
seriously thinking about it but not yet
up to a stage of planning
not yet up to stage of planet and how do
you think he's been doing how do you
think he's been there for the last three
and a half years
i saw your interview this morning with
cbs i thought it was very interesting
what you said
came out three hours ago but how do you
think he's been doing the last three and
a half years
i think he is um in the tradition of
andrew jackson as a change agent
i think he's a very disruptive force i
think that is by design
uh he wants to have a real impact
he didn't run for president you know
just to be
in the oval office or to have air force
one he ran for president
to make profound changes and certainly
if you look for example at the federal
judges where we've just had
the most extraordinary example of
appointing the third
justice of the supreme court that's a
pretty amazing achievement
uh and he kept his word i was i was
actually close to that
actually in the meeting with him in the
spring of
uh when a number of people said to him
why don't you come up with a list
of uh 10
conservative just judges that you would
consider
so people could understand that you're
really seriously committed
to changing the judiciary and he thought
it was a good idea
uh leonard leo of the federalist society
played a
key role in putting the list together
it's a
very very solid list and he's basically
kept his word
and he was fortunate because the senate
republican leader mitch mcconnell
understood the long-term historic
implications
of getting judges approved and as a
result
focused the senate republicans on
confirmation of judges as their number
one goal and has had
extraordinary impact i mean i think
there are 340 or 350
federal judges that have been approved
not counting the sort of
secondary judges but the actual the main
district judge's appeals court
and supreme court and the trump legacy
in the courts will be there for two
generations i mean
if you look at it justice barrett is i
think 48 years old
she could easily serve past
2016. that's how long the reach of the
trump presidency will be
that's unbelievable to have it 6-3 is he
the
the last president that had three
supreme court justices is is it
reagan is it the last time that happened
was three
it was three and i i can't remember i
thought it was nixon but
it's been a while been a while this this
is the
first time you've had a clear
conservative majority on the court
since 1935-36 wow
wow would you put that as his top
accomplishment would you put that at the
top or would you
but israel would you put a couple things
above that
well i think in terms of long-term
history you have to rate that as the top
one because it
when you move the courts back to a
constitutional
interpretation of the law and you put
judges in who think that they are not
there to be
independent interpreters of their own
version
you know the the supreme court has slid
to a point
where it was a permanent constitutional
convention and if you could get five
judges you could rewrite anything you
wanted to
now you've got a group of judges who
actually think that the
constitution's a living document created
by the founders
agreed to by the people of the united
states and that you have to
interpret within the framework of the
constitution
and i thought that justice barris
description uh at the white house when
she was sworn in
uh and she described the difference
between a politician
who has a duty to think about policy and
changing policy and a judge who has a
duty
not to think about policy but to think
about interpreting the law
that the politicians have written and i
thought she did a very eloquent job
of distinguishing uh the two missions
and the two roles and so i can give her
a lot of credit
yeah she the way she handled herself
those few days i mean it was teflon you
couldn't get anything on her it wasn't
like teflon like she's good at being
teflon
she was just teflon being herself she
wasn't trying to be teflon
but you know it's a great cartoon
remember when she
she holds up her notepad and it's blank
yeah
well there's a cartoon where somebody
wrote on the car on the note card
and has her holding a note card that
says i have seven children
i'm used to answering dumb questions
i saw a lot of memes but i didn't see
that one that's hilarious yeah she
by the way isn't she the first one first
woman ever to have children that are
still going to school
that she's going to be sitting on the
supreme court justice i mean she's the
first one i believe that's doing that
she is the first one uh she's look there
are a lot of things that are interesting
about
trump's decision she is the only person
on the court
who didn't go to harvard or yale she is
clearly a representative of the midwest
as she pointed out as a notre dame
graduate she probably
can educate the others a little bit
about football
she has i think a background
both in terms of her faith and the
degree to which
her life has been defined by family and
faith
in a way that i think for a lot of more
traditional women
makes her a role model that they can
really look up to she hasn't given up
anything
unlike the the liberal feminist version
you know
and she's had a great career she is a
serious intellectual
uh she is now in the highest court in
the land
she has a great family uh they have
shown
great compassion uh and uh there's just
a lot to
to the uh amy coney barrett story that i
think speaks well
and it speaks well of donald trump uh i
think that
the fact that he would pick this woman
um he had several other choices
and mitch mcconnell apparently went to
him as a midwesterner from kentucky
and said you know the easiest person for
me to get to unify
the senate republicans is is judge
barrett because uh
she's very highly respected she's very
solid
uh and you know don't go picking
somebody who's a bigger risk
because i've got a narrow margin here
yeah i think it turned out that it was a
home run
it almost seemed like he chose the
perfect candidate they would they had
nothing to come after her i mean
kavanaugh you could have brought him
from so many different angles
you couldn't say anything to her because
of who she was and by the way she was
number one in her class at notre dame i
mean she was somebody that was top notch
at what she was doing
but going back to this whole 6-3 score
you know this is not good whether you're
republican or democrat whether the other
side's got six three or you got six
three the topic of court packing came up
in the vp
debate where mike pence cornered kamala
harris you probably saw this
where he's like so are you guys going to
be packing the court are you guys going
to be packing a court and kamala did her
smile where she's looking at the
moderator hoping to change the topic and
then he finally says i hope everybody
realizes she did not answer the question
and then
she said you want me to answer the
question i'll answer the question
you know diversity is the angle she went
in and you saw biden's been trying to
answer it in a 60 minutes question
do you think they're going to pack the
court if they win and if yes what does
that really mean
to america well look i think if they get
a big enough majority
in the senate and the house they're
absolutely going to pack the court and
the reason simple
how do you go to your left-wing activist
and say to them yes it's true
we have to put up with a trump court for
the next 30 or 40 years but after all
that's the game because the activists
are going to say no no
there's an alternative game now when
president franklin delano roosevelt
tried to do this in 1937 when he was
very frustrated
uh with the conservative court uh the
whole country rebelled
he was at this peak of popularity he had
just gotten re-elected carrying all the
two states
uh and it just crashed and burned uh he
was he was very shocked
at how rapidly his popularity collapsed
when people decided he's going to try to
do something that they saw as a threat
to the constitution
so you know i think they will absolutely
try to pack the court
but i believe the reason this is such a
consequential election
is that i really do think that kamala
harris is a san francisco radical
i think nancy pelosi is a san francisco
radical
i think that schumer is going to run
scared because aoc
is potentially going to run against you
in the primary in 2022
uh and i think biden is so weak uh so
lacking in energy and in some ways so
much uh no longer in touch with reality
that i think uh he's clearly not going
to be able to control his own
administration
it's going to be dominated i think by
harris and pelosi
newt your your entire life they've been
following politics when did you start
following politics how old were you
uh what year was it when he started
following politics
well i mean i i had an uncle who'd been
very active as a republican precinct
worker in pennsylvania
so my my oldest memory is watching the
convention on television in 1956 with
eisenhower
but i really got involved because my dad
was a career
soldier and we were stationed in orleans
france
and he took us uh in the spring of 58
to the battlefield of verdun which is
the largest battle
in the western front in world war one
about uh
six hundred thousand men french and
germans were killed
in a nine month period and they have a
huge building called the ossuary
that has the bones of about a hundred
thousand of them that had been blown
apart
and couldn't be identified we spent
three days there touring the battlefield
during the day
and staying with a friend of my father's
who had been
drafted sent to the philippines served
in the bataan death march
and spent three and a half years in a
japanese prison camp which ruined his
health
so the army gave him a pretty soft job
that he could work at until retirement
so he spent all that time looking at the
cost of defeat and the cost of war
then the french paratroopers came back
from algeria
and kale literally killed the french
fourth republic
and brought general de gaulle back and
he founded the fifth republic which
still exists today it's the longest
serving
non-royalty government in the history of
france then we moved in june early july
to stuttgart which was the 7th army
headquarters in germany
and arrived the week that there was the
first berlin crisis
and the us army had gone into lebanon
with nuclear weapons offshore
so with all that stuff going on i was
going to be either a
vertebrate paleontologist or a zoo
director and
i spent all summer thinking and praying
about it
and decided that it was my job to
basically
do three things figure out what we have
to do to survive
figure out how to explain it so the
american people would give us permission
and then figure out how you would
implement it once you had permission
since august of 1958
uh that's what i've been doing so i
guess 62 years august of 1958 so that
leads me to my question
who have been the worst
presidential candidates both on the left
and the right if you were to say
the worst candidates that either parties
put up as a front runner who would you
say those have been in the last 62 years
well i think the the two who had the
most impossible job were barry goldwater
who
was both too far to the right and didn't
understand how to try to bring his party
together
and george mcgovern who really
was the first modern radical nominee and
who felt that he had to
focus on the radical wing of his party
both of them lost
disastrously and both of them
i think left behind in mcgovern's case
it's the beginning of the radical
movement the democratic party
and goldwater's case that leads directly
to reagan and the rise of modern
conservatism
but i would say as candidates those were
the two who had the hardest time
where would you put maidan as
who what would you put biden he'll buy
ness
biden is unique i mean biden is a guy
first of all you have to give him some
credit
he's the nominee he outlasted everybody
else
second they have a very clear strategy
if this election is about trump they
believe they will win
if this election is a choice between
trump and biden they think they will
lose
so their job is to hide like a bunny in
the basement
and hope that the country doesn't notice
him and the problem is every time he
comes out
he says something goofy yeah and and uh
loses ground so uh you know i personally
think as of today he's going to lose
when he loses the left is going to go
crazy so it's going to be just like
philadelphia has been the last couple
nights
and you're going to see days of rage
because
they've been told over and over again by
totally inaccurate polls
that biden's way ahead well biden's not
way ahead
but at best this is a very close race
from the standpoint of democrats and at
worst it's going to turn out to be a
republican sweep
and nobody's factoring that in because
if they don't know how to
they don't know how to ask the right
questions and they have learned nothing
from how wrong they were in 2016.
remember on election day in 2016.
the new york times said there was an 85
percent likelihood that hillary clinton
would win
on election day yeah so
these people have learned nothing and uh
we'll find out
next week whether i'm right or there
right do you think we're going to find
that next week or do things going to be
delayed
oh no i think the margin will be big
enough we'll know oh we'll know next
week okay i think i'm gonna beat him
badly enough
that you'll you'll know okay that's
that's good to know i got three topics
to get into hopefully before we wrap up
number one you said 92 percent of
coverage of trump is negative on tv
jeff bezos just came out saying he's
planning on buying cnn what are your
thoughts if jeff bezos now owns
washington post and ends up buying and
owning cnn what happens to media
i don't know cnn has been so badly uh
left-wing zucker's done such a terribly
one-sided hatchet job that probably
can't get a whole lot worse without
losing
all of its viewers so it depends on what
basis wants to do i've been very
disappointed that bezos has not
imposed more order on the washington
post and the washington post
used to be a serious newspaper right now
it's a left wing propaganda right
and that's really tragic you know if
you'd had the scale of
scandal that the biden family has uh
in the 1970s imagine when when woodward
and bernstein went to see bradley the
managing editor and said you know we
want to dig into this watergate thing
and he said nah skip it let's not bother
nixon
it's inconceivable yet we have all sorts
of evidence eyewitnesses
uh laptop computer data that
the biden family not hunter biden the
biden family
has been engaged in absolute corruption
uh and the new york times the washington
post all these
places cnn all of them have hidden it
because they're trying to protect the
bunny in the basement
uh and i think that uh you know it'll be
interesting i'm very sad
that bezos has not insisted on some
level of uh
professionalism at the washington post
so so then my question goes to fox
because
if i'll turn your attention to this one
part of an interview you did
on fox a couple weeks ago a few weeks
ago
i think with harrison uh harris faulkner
i want to get your reaction on this
this is you on fox news on september 9th
i believe
progressive district attorneys are
anti-police
pro-criminal and overwhelmingly elected
with george soros's money
and they're a major cause of the
violence we're seeing
because they keep putting the violent
criminals back on the street
i'm not sure we need to bring us into
this i was going to say you get the last
word speaker
he paid for it i mean why can't we
discuss the fact that millions of
dollars
i agree with george doesn't need to be a
part of this conversation
okay so it's verbose
all right okay i mean that's got to be
one of the most uncomfortable moments of
tv whether it's fox or
and you're seeing murdoch's sons uh
recently giving
money to the democratic party so the
reason why i'm saying this is
if fox goes left and an interview like
that happens i want to get your reaction
on that period
but if fox goes left what's the only
media channel that's left for the right
to you know
give daughter side of the argument well
i mean first of all
what you saw was a mistake on and then
fox had no problem with talking about
soros
and in fact the next day um
she she apologized uh for
uh the way it was mishandled and what
had happened was we were
she harris harris or the lady in the
yellow okay
but the other woman is a professional
democrat and was doing her job which is
to clutter it up
and try to not let us score points
against democrats
uh harris i think because we were
separated it was all virtual
i was i think actually in rome at the
time uh and so
uh harris was a half step back uh in in
sort of sorting it out because it was
wasn't like we were on the same couch
uh the next day i did her show and she
openly apologized and said look
we would never cut you you know we love
having you on etc
so i think it was actually a technical
mistake now having said that
if at some point fox decides to become
a left-wing establishment channel
there will be three or four channels uh
probably starting with newsmax
but there will be three or four
different channels competing to replace
fox
i don't think the fox audience is going
to go with fox if it becomes a left-wing
channel
nor nor by the way when i look at their
lineup
uh i mean i i don't i don't think you
know that that
tucker or sean or or laura are about to
become
moderates so they did they would have a
long way to go and i do fox and friends
all the time
uh and i i feel very comfortable doing
all these shows
and generally speaking uh they're
probably not quite
as far to the right as they were under
ales but they're still
far and away uh the most effective
conservative vehicle in the country
well tucker's coming up for renewal of a
contract if he was an athlete he's
underpaid because he's getting six
million and hannah is getting 25
and he just passed them up on viewership
i know your friends you probably can't
say anything about it but
did you watch tucker yesterday with uh
tony bublinski the guest he had on
no i've seen him take the outtakes from
it robin i didn't watch the whole show
what what's your reaction with the story
of tony coming out with the partnership
of honor i know you went into it briefly
earlier when i was asking you about
bezos and cnn
but what are your thoughts about it and
why is it that no one's covering it it's
like
almost saying i heard somebody say the
other day i think it was on 60 minutes
or one of the
hosts said well we won't cover it
because everything is speculation
nothing we don't
cover stories like this if it's if it
isn't 100
what are your thoughts about what we're
seeing with tony and hunter biden well
first that comments a lie
they spent three and a half years
covering a russian story about trump
that turned out to be totally
false uh both the new york times the
washington post got pulitzer prizes
for covering lies which uh they never to
return the prizes but
their entire prize is based on lies so
if you're on the left
you can do anything you want to and
they'll protect you if you're on the
right they can
smear you and claim that it's good
journalism uh
let's just start with with honesty um
second i just did a 30-minute video
uh which is available at gingrich 360.
uh on
the bro the biden family corruption and
uh i think i outline it with quotes and
with video
and lay the whole thing out it's much
more than hunter it's it's a
it's a family business it's his two
uncles it's his father
uh and they were just out going around
the planet scooping up money
uh clearly a blatant uh violation
of public trust uh and and uh and it's
an astonishing story well it involves
hundreds of millions of dollars now this
is not some small
you know jaywalking problem um i
i have seen excerpts from polinsky
uh you know he was a naval officer he
has a good reputation
we have some mutual friends who think
very highly of him
but again you have what you have is the
entire
establishment twitter
facebook um all the major media
are like they're like they're like a
greek phalanx
they're all lined up to protect biden
and so they want to make sure that the
bunny in the basement is safe
while they go and attack the bear and
that's what this race is all about you
think the world's dangerous
and we need a bear in which case donald
trump's a pretty good candidate
or you think that donald trump is the
problem and we could really survive as a
country
with a bunny rabbit as our president as
our president which i think is
just laughable impossible and and i'm
very interested to see how people vote
next week
because i think the more we watch biden
you know things like referring to
kamala harris's wife which he did
yesterday
or the day before referring twice to
george when he met donald trump
or announcing he was running for the
senate three or four days ago
i mean the more you watch biden the more
you know
this is not a guy who is really ready
for prime time
last question for you is with nancy
pelosi speaker of the house
she was on the wolf build sir i'm sure
you saw that interview she had
which wolf pushed her on a little bit
saying how come you're not calling trump
and she says i don't call trump
i'm not going to call trump i talk to
his people there's no way i'm going to
call trump like she was offended
that wolf asked about calling trump you
were speaker to house before
at a time where you were a disruptor i
mean if people go back and study what
you did you would be categorized as a
disrupter you were able to do something
that hadn't been done
for a long time when it was controlled
by the other side
what was your relationship like with the
president and as a speaker of the house
are you supposed to pick up the phone
and call them and say let's get a deal
done
look you can't compare the two um
bill clinton and i were both sort of
natural graduate students
uh we liked sitting around talking about
ideas occasionally he'd call and i'd go
down and have a drink with him late at
night
and we chat very much like tip o'neill
and ronald reagan
uh we we negotiated the only balanced
budgets in your lifetime
and we did it by sitting in a room for
35 days
now that's a totally different world now
my advice if trump does get reelected
is going to be pick the 50 or 60
democrats that are most vulnerable
ignore pelosi totally and build a trump
wing of the democratic party
and just beat her on the floor i think
that's the only practical way to do it
against pelosi yeah because she's a
radical
she's not going to agree to anything wow
okay final thoughts next week you're
saying landslide victory for trump
yeah i think so i think we we increase
our number of seats in the senate
john james wins in michigan we pick up
the seat in alabama
uh we have an outside but real shot in
new mexico
um our candidates are all going to do
much better than people think
uh the incumbents in running for
re-election uh so i'm i'm
i'm pretty optimistic and i think trump
will people need to remember trump had
300 and some electoral votes
uh and i think he's likely to be uh in
that range again
and maybe higher uh i think he's now
carrying
north carolina he's carrying florida
he's carrying iowa he's carrying arizona
uh i actually think he's ahead in
pennsylvania i've seen three polls that
i trust
that show him up in pennsylvania it's
very important to know what poll you're
looking at
most of these public polls are pure junk
they don't know what they're doing they
don't poll correctly they don't ask the
right questions
and they don't reach the right people so
and i think that the fracking
get rid of fossil fuels
by biden are just devastating uh and
particularly in states like pennsylvania
and texas
and new mexico which polls do you trust
you said it's important you trust
the right people the poll i trust the
most is trafalgar
uh which is uh was the most accurate in
16 and most accurate in 18.
and to give an example of how bad polls
can be quinnipiac which is a very
respectable establishment poll
had both the republican senate and
governor candidates in
florida losing by seven points the day
before
the election they both won the election
got it that's very good to know new
thank you so much we're going to get
somebody
appreciate take care bye-bye
so they say newt gingrich is one of the
smartest man in politics the last 34
years because he studied this game he's
been in the game he knows the people
and he's got different perspectives he
can give you i'm curious you know what
you took away from the interview
comment below i want to hear your
thoughts and then if you watch this
interview and you enjoyed it
there's another interview i did a few
weeks ago with dinesh d'souza
on his new documentary if you've not
watched it click over here to watch that
documentary interview that we did
together and if you've not subscribed to
the channel please
do so thanks for watching everybody take
care bye